[Music]
what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time or
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here with the mls
oh wait just kidding plano uh don't
forget that lunch money is now sponsored
by block five block five has
three products they buy and sell crypto
on a crypto exchange they allow you to
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan and get your crypto collateral
or three is you get two deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account
you're not going to find rates like that
anywhere in the fiat
traditional world so go check out block
5 go to blockbuy.com
i'm an investor i sit on the board and i
am a very happy user
you will be a very happy user too if you
get a block by accountblockby.com
what's up guys three seconds before this
video was recorded he put his hoodie on
backwards
and had the hood like this by accident
it's okay my eyeball
something's going on with my eye over
here i'm working on it i don't can't
tell what's going on
can't might be a stye might be pink guy
might be covered who knows
but i'm here i'm excited and i am
delivering you guys
the goods all right joe biden president
joe biden will on tuesday meet with the
chief executives of some of the
country's largest
businesses uh to discuss biden's
1.9 trillion dollar stimulus plan and
the outlook for the american economy
uh him and janet yellen are meeting with
jp morgan's jamie diamond walmart's doug
mcmillan
gaps sonya single lowe's marvin ellison
and tom donahoe of the us chamber of
commerce
converse commerce you know who i don't
see on here
wacky ceos like no you want to know
who's not there
the people i thought the stimulus was
all about helping the people why does jp
morgan who's had record profits over the
last year what do they need the stimulus
for
the people no what do they need the
stimulus for what does
walmart need to be there for the
stimulus talk what does gap
need to be there ain't nobody trying to
buy clothes people just trying to get
food on the table and survive
and these people why they got those you
wanna know who should go talk to
go talk to the small business owners go
talk to the people on the street
they're the people who need help jp
morgan don't need help jpmorgan's doing
just fine
in fact jp morgan had record profits
they're doing better than they've ever
done but you know who's not doing well
is the 40 percent of businesses in new
york city they've been shut down
go help those people how about you do a
meeting with them
wow ain't nobody want to do that
everybody wants to just sit around and
talk to all the rich wealthy
uh super freaking influential people
ain't nobody at jp morgan that works
there or uh
does anything there need help the real
people
that need help they're not part of the
conversation i would if i was president
vote for paulina 2020 um
if i was president i would get all these
like small business owners and let them
yell at me
and then come up with a policy because
people are angry
of course they're mad also i love that
they're talking about
it's like it's like oh how do we help
the american people and then it's like a
star-studded panel of bankers how do we
help the american people oh i don't know
let's go
ask a bunch of dudes who run banks and
large corporations
and then oh let's also get the woman who
runs gaap and the uh
the uh um treasury like a good
representation of america
all right you know who they need to meet
with they need to meet with me
that's what i'm gonna start advocating
for you want to talk about what the
solutions are
meet with me mark cuban is getting in
on the audio and podcasting hype okay
don't do that look at what he's doing
put that away this is this is
stopping okay so
um more cuban is getting in on the
audio and podcasting hype
[Laughter]
i don't know why it's so funny alongside
co-founder fallon fatih
fatemi he's planning to launch fireside
a next-gen podcast platform
that facilitates live conversation um
the app idea is similar to the buzzy
live audio startup clubhouse except the
ability to natively record
conversations so we've been talking
about this recently but honestly i don't
think mark cuban stands a chance against
clubhouse a clubhouse competitor
done by mark cuban i'm sorry no all your
sharks are on clubhouse
mr wonderful barbara corker and damon
john they're all on clubhouse
mark what if they all go to the fireside
they won't go to france although i think
it'll be interesting
because fireside does let you record
so that's interesting we will see
we will see what happens i like free
market competition there it wants to be
a competitor in the marketplace
let's go can we just reflect that
twitter couldn't compete with clubhouse
but mark cuban will how do you know
again that's not true no it is true they
started
uh audio stories last year then they
started spaces which was supposed to be
a clubhouse computer have you have you
gone on spaces do you know what spaces
is there's people on spaces
all day long whoo go look right now go
get your phone and go
even now all right go keep going and
i'll pull up spaces but what is it an
app is it on twitter where does it look
go ahead i'm waiting
sorry nobody's on spaces guys spaces is
empty
you seem to be fleeting you seem to be
fleeing but i'm not spacing
a lot of fleeting going on
go ahead i have been fleeting a lot okay
oh reddit but that's not where spaces
you don't even know how to
find let's go come on i see a lot of
fleeting going on here
you you were talking uh badly about that
down put it down this is not an
opportunity for you to scroll through
your twitter
reddit david marcus just liked my tweet
that you shouldn't have pineapple
on pizza we're not even going to get
into it today
put your cord down reddit races
sound like a little limp reddit raises
250 million
dollars at six at a six billion dollar
valuation
wow sources say this is pre-money
um the six billion and the company has
doubled its valuation since this last
funding round of 300 million
at a three billion values from 2019 who
is investing in this
what what was the 1.8 billion what do
you mean that's the round i did 1.8
billion valuation it doesn't say
that then let's go back yeah right there
there's a chart so they raised 50 on 500
then they raised 200 at 1.8
i put a very very small check into that
through
spv then they raised 300 at 3 billion
bang bang and now they just raised 250
at 6. wow
hey we own a growth pack by the way it's
undervalued this company should be worth
10 plus billion dollars in my personal
opinion
but what do i know i just okay do you
think about it much lower than that do
you think that the
the wsb people had something to do with
this
like in terms of i mean definitely
there's a bunch of attention to it and
people
are are out raising money but uh it
sounds like robin hood raised more money
at a higher valuation
so what was robinson's valuation
recently uh
i forget okay well you can't say
anything
higher but it's higher than six spacex
once again widened the scope of the
public beta test of its starlink
satellite
internet service um elon musk's company
on monday will be
has begun has began whatever to accept
pre-orders from potential customers for
this
internet uh prospective starlink users
can enter a service
address on the company's website with
pre-orders available for 99
wow look this is going to be
absolutely is this gonna be like super
fast internet yeah this is gonna be
absolutely explosive
explosive it is watch
but is it like basically it's gonna
bring internet to rural areas that
normally have really shitty service or
is it gonna like improve my internet
today
in miami uh well it depends on where you
are
right and depends on where the
satellites are rotating around
you know nothing okay no for real that's
what that's how it works you have to
have the size what's the point of
starling because my question
is it to bring it to rural areas and
places it is definitely to decrease the
cost and increase the accessibility of
the internet because we're gonna beat me
down from space
so if i don't know anything that sounds
like i knew something the nfl's 2021
super bowl
attracted 96.4 million viewers it's the
lowest
watched super bowl since 2007 when the
colts played the bears
hold on a second i thought that they
were expecting very high viewership
because people are at home
they have nothing to do they're watching
some ball
you see how i said ball not football
what
why anybody don't watch this stupid game
eli manning and the giants aren't
playing
daniel jones and the giants aren't
playing saquon barkley and the giants
weren't playing
nobody cares literally nobody cares if
the giants ain't playing nobody cares
that is actually false if i played in
the super bowl everybody would watch but
no they no literally nobody would watch
yesterday nobody would watch it
and by the way they also uh the weekend
him and i were cool
until the halftime show what was that he
paid 7 million
out of pocket to perform i don't care
just
look can we bring out
a guest performer that puts on a
show i'm talking about a real show not a
i'm gonna walk around in between this
thing and play some like you know the
the same beats that get played inside of
starbucks like ain't nobody want kind of
like the coffee shop
what kind of show would you put on i'm
talking about bring out nwa and let's
start it off with
you know the hard-hitting stuff you guys
want to see some people watch
or how about snoop dogg let's bring
snoop dogg out and martha stewart
martha stewart can dance around do
whatever she wants maybe cook up a
little
uh scrambled eggs that's fine but what
i'm saying is if you bring out
nwa or you bring out snoop dogg or
how about jay-z that's what we should
bring out let's bring out jay-z and
beyonce and that show will be
poppin and you're gonna have 100 plus
million people watching
for my birthday he got me a concert
ticket to
um concert tickets to the beyonce jay-z
concert
in new york it was amazing it was the
best gift ever did you like it
yeah it was cool because jay-z's the man
so that's what i'm talking about
you know who else you could speak you
could bring out lil wayne
and have him play lil wayne would have
been better
than the weekend do you realize the
weekend needs to go back to the weekend
these people they are not paid fun fact
the super bowl okay but to convince
jay-z
to go over there and perform for no
money j-lo did it
yeah but jlo okay i'm just saying
i'm gonna start a petition we need jay-z
doing the half-time show
i don't know what we watched alright
ready well actually
nobody was watching yeah just a few
million people
uh hashtag ask lm
ask your questions in the comments with
the hashtag
askgalon tate smith pomp i'm deploying
for nine months and i want to fill my
downtime
learning more about btc specifically how
can i develop skills
that benef that could benefit me with
work or profit later in life
i've been reviewing how to set up a
lightning node but what but want to get
your take thanks again for all the info
paulina is a catch well thank you tate
listen oh my god he just said destiny
no no no oh so we forget to turn on the
light this is why it's bad lighting guys
sorry uh two things one is
uh i would just continue to study
bitcoin
literally go from the technology all the
way up to the
economics and everything in between uh
one of the things that
i think you can do is uh there's
probably 10 to 20
information sources uh there's a lot of
podcasts
there's a number of people who are very
prolific writers all that kind of stuff
just consume everything they put out so
it's not a book or anything it's just
stay on top of it all and over time
you'll just get more and more knowledge
as they kind of explain things as
they're going
so podcast and you have special ones
so i like marty bendt uh a lot uh i like
both his podcasts and running i'm gonna
throw out names and then you can pick
from there
so marty bent comes to mind preston pish
comes to mind uh robert breedlove comes
to mind michael saylor obviously
pump letter uh yeah that um
you know there's a ton of books that are
out there obviously bitcoin standard
there's also i think a really
interesting element
on on twitter if you follow people like
nick carter
uh does a great job um melton
uh um caitlyn long you can kind of just
like go to the line just follow a bunch
of these people
and and you'll get kind of in the flow
of of what's going on
uh ryan sulcus at massari does a great
job uh bitwise has a great
uh study that they put out periodically
so all that
then the other thing that i would do is
i wouldn't just read about bitcoin
the other thing that i would do is i
would spend time
uh doing two things one is i would learn
as much as i could about personal
finance and wealth creation
so rich dad poor dad richest man in
babylon
um think and grow rich like there's just
a ton of books and i would just go learn
as much about that as i can
actually when i was deployed that's what
those three books specifically i read
while i was deployed and then the other
thing i would do is i would study the
world's most successful people so things
like the profile
which i'm really mad i have just plugged
that uh-hum
but also i would go and i would read
like the biographies of different
uh folks um it's just fascinating to
kind of see like jp morgan andrew
carnegie
ben franklin right you just go through
and you and you study these people and
you realize
here's what they've done in their life
then you can come to more modern day
like jeff bezos
uh elon musk history repeats itself
steve jobs etc
so i think that's kind of how i would
approach it that's awesome
alex brockhob pomp what is the single
biggest risk bitcoin will face in the
next decade self-inflicted wounds
somebody introduces a
um some sort of uh bug to the code hey i
just said that the other day and you
said no
it's not gonna happen but joey destacio
love the video guys paulina i just read
your profile on mental frameworks it was
an absolute game changer ah thank you
okay he went on to say some really nice
things about me and my thing
my question for both of you is would you
rather be the only human living
on an alien planet or the only alien
living on a human
planet i would go with only alien
on a human planet because you get to
study all the humans it would be
it would be oh wait hold on a second
only human
on an alien planet or only no i would
want to be the alien on the human planet
for sure
because i could be like look at these
weird things and then like you know i
would be able to introduce them to
new technology and new new things
i personally think that we're all aliens
we're just aliens to some other
intelligent species would you rather be
yours like you as a human on another
intelligent
alien species planet or would you rather
be an alien on this planet i'd like to
be alien on this yeah i'd be
screwing all you all but it would be
kind of cool to go over there and learn
their culture and stuff
i think all right that's it for today
black hoodies black t-shirts jay-z at
the halftime show
and life is good only if the giants are
playing
go g man see y'all tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends